brian bring y'all know comp pro m game
play in a minute this is a little draft
league right here so you know when it
comes to draft league it's a whole bunch
of egos just a whole bunch of people
talking crazy this lock was hounding
before we even got drafted now look at
this center telemind is business i don't
play that that's the highlight camera
for i see everything going on in that
corner he just got steamed
like bro i ain't gonna lie i'm telling
y'all this is where you put egos to rest
right here as you can see crap look at
this center i sort of sting them again
i should have stained them again but
they got a little three man he crabbed
up y'all already know what time it is
but yeah brother draft league that's hey
if you want to get your name out here a
little bit
play the little triathletes bro you know
what i'm saying people mess with you but
y'all see me off the uh
he was one of my favorites but yeah
though the draft please be where it's at
people talk crazy i'll talk y'all know i
love to talk crazy
i love to talk crazy i talk nasty like
look at me snatch oh
man
man
like man i'm telling you all i don't
play that bro like when they come to
static i want it all like bro i'll talk
crazy and i back it up and if i don't
i'ma still talk crazy because i'm gonna
say hey gg but now i'm back to work you
feel me the story never ends he is
behind me like my past